The ICU is really where you
go when you're very sick.
It's a really intense
interventionist environment.
And so, when you're
in the ICU, you really
need to know how acutely
ill an individual is
so you can decide whether you
need to specify treatments
very quickly, or
whether you need
to focus more care on them.
There is a tremendous
amount of information
that the doctors and nurses
and all of the care staff
are actually encoding in some
of these notes that they take.
And a lot of that is
just harder to access.
It's not a nice set of codes
that are already presorted
in some very easy-to-use way.
It's just sort of this free
text that's a sprawl and very
difficult to use.
But probably contains
more informative things
about the underlying
patient state.
So there's patient and
he's really, really sick.
And then there's a doctor,
and she's totally overwhelmed.
Because patients
generates so much data,
there's basically a zillion
notes and constant signals who
can keep up with 1,000 hertz.
Oh, yeah, I guess there's also
that other stuff, like age
and gender and acuity scores.
Seems pretty important
to think about.
And maybe that would all be OK
if there was just one patient,
but there are so, so many
patients in a modern ICU.
So here's what this
doctor really wants.
She'd like a real-time indicator
of how sick each patient is.
And let's see on a scale of
faking it to dead, and maybe
beyond?
But how can she get that?
That's where we come in.
We can predict how
sick patients are
by looking at their notes,
which is great because there's
a lot of notes, nearly half a
million, from 19,308 patients.
Using a couple of magical,
fancy-looking plates
we can model common topics
that we find in the notes.
And then, for each
patient, we can figure out
which topics are the
most relevant to them.
Then you say, hey,
I feel like you're
saying a lot of words
that are related
to the topic of septic shock.
You may not think your patient
is going through septic shock,
but maybe they're going
to at some point soon.
So maybe you should take
a look at them right now,
or try some more interventionist
techniques at this point.
If you look at our population,
the baseline mortality
is about 11%.
But what we can see is
the relative mortality
of the topics is pretty
different from that.
Some are really
high, like this one
that looks like it's about
respiratory failure with words
like intubated and
vents, secretions.
Definitely not a topic
you want in your notes.
But some are really
low, like this one
that looks like it's
about broken bones.
Broken bones hurt, but they
don't usually kill you.
And even better,
we can look at how
the topics change in time for
each new note that comes in,
which is great because
usually the information
that a doctor gets at
admission, that baseline data,
is less and less
predictive over time.
Since the notes accumulate,
they don't start off
doing that well, but they
get more and more predictive.
And when we use both of
them together and combine
the models, it helps us
get a prediction that's
great from the time the
patient shows up to the time
that they leave the hospital.
Everything I hear about now
related to clinical care
is all about, can we make
more space for doctors
to be doctors and
less room for them
to be accountants, and
note takers, and, you know,
transcribists?
Or, whatever it is, right?
We want to allow
doctors to actually feel
like they're making decisions
about a patient's care.
Right?
And what I would hope
is, if a system like this
really was implemented, it
would allow doctors to spend
more time caring for patients.